all right brian we are at comic con
let's talk about what's the coolest
thing what do you like about these wild
fan conventions because it is chaos i
went in there today it was my first time
and i was like
holy cow what's in it for you what do
you like about us costumes are amazing
and passion is amazing i mean i've never
met
people that are as passionate about
films and television as i mean look we
have somebody in the costume right now
stretching on the stairs for for the
fights oh she's jumping over the wall
yeah it's so great right now
i love comic-con
it is fun the people only in san diego
will you see this yeah and i mean they
show up and show out to support this
game oh man it's crazy
but i i get it i mean i've i've seen the
people out here i understand it i you
know i on a much smaller level
um
feel that way about star wars so it's
like you know i get people wanting to
come together and celebrate the things
that they love so i it's
i i enjoy it yeah i love i love seeing
passion like this a congratulations is
obviously an order from a dad to a dad
thank you congrats on baby zane how's
how's baby how's mama sharna how's
everybody holding up and and enjoying
the first you know those those first
moments zayn is awesome three weeks old
um tuesday
sharon is amazing she's an amazing mom
i have five kids
we joke
we joke about the fact that i had a
i already had a station wagon so now i
have a yukon denali
if
if i have another one
um then i'm moving to like a sprinter or
a school bus or something like that
you're a limo driver too you're a limo i
have to and then it's the thought of
like okay how do you travel like how you
know going into a restaurant asking for
a table for seven it's it all starts
becoming a little much so
i i think i think i'm done at five
wait wait let me rewind the interview to
never say never just rewind it to that
right now no i'm not saying never
you notice i'm saying i think
and and there there there's a lot that
can come from thinking there there's
there's a lot of room room for change
within that how are your dad feels have
the boys all got to meet zayn
the kids are so amazing with zane they
they were they were amazing with sharna
the whole time when she was pregnant and
they like
they would come in every morning and
they would want a rubber belly and they
would talk to him and they're just
obsessed with him and they come in every
morning now is he awake yet and you know
they tiptoe around it's they're so cute
it's so cool and even
even the then youngest one journey um
really
it's amazing for him now not being the
baby of the family and we weren't sure
you never know you know going into a
situation like that it's like how are
the kids gonna deal with another kid
being around and it's just been
really smooth sailing it's been great
the sky was the limit for them they
really were a perfect storm it was going
to unite the world but that's not going
to happen now
[Music]
the last reported sighting was at butt
holes which is a bar in the valley oh my
god
[Music]
it's them
well you're here you're repping booty
ology talk to me about booty ology
first explain the title and then tell me
what we can expect so booty so
it uh it's a documentary following uh
the booty boys who were a rap group in
in the early 2000s
um
and uh
we find them again they find themselves
again and then they decide to start uh
to start recording and performing and
doing what it is they they feel they're
best at doing um
and and booteology is just the journey
it's just the journey of that and i
suggest that anybody that hasn't seen it
uh
go see it it's it's awesome
and if you're a fan of hip-hop
they're they're super entertaining super
fun the movies buzzy underdog story is
that what sold you or was it the frozen
for 15 years plot point which is it
because i'm stuck on both i think so
so what's what's sold me on it selfishly
narcissistically because i'm an actor is
is that uh
originally they they were like oh you
know you've been mentioned in in the
project and i was like well that's i'm
sure as a joke but that's i'm still uh
i i'm still humbled and grateful for
that and then and then to sit down and
kind of get the whole story of it um
i love that i mean a
yeah frozen for for years that's kind of
a cool that's kind of a cool thing i'm a
hip-hop fan and head they they're
hip-hop heads and fans
so there was there was a lot in common
and then
ultimately just it being sort of a funny
take on on
on a very real situation i thought was
smart
yeah totally how did your relationship
how did you how do you know the booty
boys how did you come into contact how
does this all all start and evolve this
this originally came from uh sharna my
girlfriend she um
uh
bob in the film company they they've
done a lot of music for dancing with the
stars and so she originally came to me
and she was like hey so these guys did
do music on the show they're doing this
film and and you know want to talk to
you about it and i was like sounds
interesting and then when i heard about
it i got the email sort of the
description of it i was like that's
awesome yeah i have to do that sure i
love the connection now i've
i want to talk about some oscar dreams
because the team is pushing for an
academy nom for the song we are all but
men i mean dude i'm here for this and i
love it and
hip hop has a place in the oscars now
three six mafia put us on the map you
know some other some other
won an oscar yeah no it's uh chances are
i mean it's possible i anything is
possible i never say never
not in hollywood bro no
no there's always the shocking things
that we i mean we were sitting up on the
stage right now doing a panel at
comic-con
um about a film called rudiology and we
were sitting up there laughing about it
gone i can't believe this is
that we're here and this is happening
but uh
here we are
you